ابو احمد وبعد مرور ثلاثه ايام يتفقد اثار
الدمار الذي لحق بممتلكاته جراء هجوم
المستوطنين عليها بدايه الاسبوع خلال
البوابه وفات من هون يعني وحركوها
قصروا هاي السياره وحركوها
احنا كنا فوق طبعا وممنوع حدا ينزل وممنوع
او يطخ علينا دموع وقنابل صوت
وجيش احتلال
الجنود وهاي الواجهه طلع كيف كله كله على
النار جوا طبعا جوا الدار واحنا سبعه وجوا
الدار عندي خمس اولاد خمس اطفال عندي احنا
السبعه محصورين فوق
عشرات المركبات والمنشات احرقت وتركت
خلفها كم من الخوف وعدم الشعور بالامان قد
لا تستطيع جهود التضامن والدعم تبديده
حديثنا عن حمايه دوليه اشبعنا كلام اذا لم
نكن نحن بحمايه اهلنا واعتقد انه اللجان
الشعبيه هي الرد الحقيقي على كل ما يقوم
به المستوطنين من عربده وغير ذلك المجتمع
الدولي يكتب تقارير المجتمع الدولي يدين
المجتمع الدولي يستنكر ولكن بالمجمل العام
حان الوقت انه احنا شعبيا نتصدى
المستوطنين
حواره اشبهوا بمدينه اشباح يخيم عليها
الصمت والحزن كما يمنع الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصحاب المحل التجاريه من فتح ابوابها حجم
الدمار على الارض ورائحه الحرائق في
المكان تدل على حجم الخوف الذي عاشته هذه
البلده قبل ثلاثه ايام وعلى حجم قله
الحيله في توفير الحمايه للمدنيين
الفلسطينيين من بلده حواره شمال الضفه
الغربيه خالد القاسم العربيه